what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again
with another naruto video and a much
requested one
at that today we'll be looking at all
ten
tailed beats and their powers if you do
enjoy seeing these naruto videos and
want to keep them coming
the best thing you can do is smash that
like button until it's blue and leave
suggestions in the comments for what
video
you would like to see next if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell so
you don't miss future
naruto videos when they drop and while
you wait for the next one to come out
feel free to check out my growing naruto
playlist which includes videos about all
the hokage
all the uzumaki all otutsuki and much
more link to that is in the description
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
so let's get into a brief introduction
of what tailed beasts
are the nine-tailed beasts we are
familiar with came from the ten tales
more on the ten tales later
for now we just gotta know that hagoromo
aka the stage of six paths
after serving as the jinchuriki of the
ten tales decided to divide that immense
chakra into nine different living
creatures that he created using the
creation of all things technique
in addition to creating new beings this
process was also supposed to make it
more difficult for the ten tails to
resurrect the nine-tailed beasts were
supposed to help maintain
balance and peace in the world hagoromo
gave names to all nine of the tailed
beasts
on a side note the tailed beast started
out as adorable
chibi versions of their current selves
with baby kurama being especially cute
to those adorable tail beast babies
hagoromo stated that even if they were
apart
they'd always be together and eventually
the day would come
when they would be united again each of
them would have their own unique names
and different forms
at that time unlike when they were the
ten tails inside hagoromo
and at this point they would be led
properly and learn what true power is
and
that eventually happened when they
reunited inside naruto who had to learn
a whole bunch of hard names all at once
at one point obito would define the
tailed beasts as chakra monsters and
explained that long ago the first hokage
collected a few of them and kept them
under his control
each time a great shinobi war threatened
hashirama
used them to maintain the power balance
and distributed them to other lands
starting with the five principal
territories as proof of alliances or
agreements unlike the sage of six paths
subsequent people view detailed beasts
as
chakra weapons which is why many tailed
beasts developed antagonistic
relationships with people
despite the fact that they came from a
person albeit an alien
god-like one like hagoromo hashirama
wanted to use a tail beasts to help
maintain
balance but the problem was the first
hokage used the tailed beasts forcefully
without their consent or cooperation
it took naruto asura otutsuki's latest
reincarnation
to finally figure out that they should
be treated as equals and friends rather
than just
as weapons with that basic info out of
the way let's start things off with the
one tail
shukaku as we know shukaku was sealed
inside
saint-kinggara who served as its
red-haired and eyebrowless jinchuriki
the tailed beasts are based off of
different animals and shukaku is based
off of
a tanuki or japanese raccoon dog
shukaku's first jin shuriki was a nice
elderly priest who reminded shukaku of
this age of six paths because he treated
the tailed beasts with respect
bunpuku was his name and pacifism was
his game
even though the way people treated him
was insane lighthearted rhyming aside
the tsunagakure village
viewed him as a monster and kept him in
jail despite the fact that he was doing
them
a huge service by being the jinchuriki
so no one else had to be
what i really respect about this guy is
his zen monk level of acceptance and
gratefulness
rather than hating shukaku because being
its vessel meant being separated from
all other humans he was
always nice to shukaku and grateful for
its company
even if the villagers forgot his name he
was grateful that shukaku knew his name
and when asked if he ever got lonely
because he could only communicate with a
man-hating beast he responded and i
quote
there's no need to distinguish between
man and beast a friend of the heart
provides peace of mind
no matter the species end quote i think
anyone who's ever had a pet dog can
relate to that bunpuku
counted his blessings and never blamed
others knowing that no matter their
actions
fundamentally people's hearts wish to
connect with and accept each other
rather than being sad bunpuku cried
tears of joy and gratitude when shukaku
told him he reminded it of the sage of
six paths
and then bunpuku revealed it was the
nicest thing anyone had ever said to him
although we don't know his name we know
that shukaku's jinchuriki
before gara inspired the third
kazikage's iron sand technique
eventually gar inherited the tailed
beast and his father the fourth kazikage
arguably the worst that in anime
labelled his jinchuriki son a failed
experiment because he couldn't control
shukaku and his emotions
and i don't think any kid could if they
were constantly
the target of assassins and if they were
also convinced that the few people who
loved them
actually hated them and wanted to see
them dead
gara more than anyone deserves to talk
to a therapist about his childhood
trauma and daddy issues
and when you combine all that with
insomnia and shukaku's hatred of humans
by this point you obviously get a less
tame jinchuriki biju combo than when an
enlightened monk is in charge but enough
about bad parenting
let's dig up some info about shukaku
skills like all tailed beasts
shukaku comes along with a massive
amount of chakra and the ability to fire
off tailed beast balls aka biju bombs
when the user falls asleep shukaku can
take full control and go on a rampage
which is why early gara feared sleep and
was constantly sleep deprived leading to
an
even more unstable personality now let's
talk ninjutsu
shukaku is known for his sand
manipulation
shukaku's body is made of sand and it
can further use sand to attack or defend
it takes pride in the absolute sand
defense shukaku has the ability to use
grand
sand mausoleum seal to trap an opponent
in a sand pyramid that is further
strengthened
by the curse marks on shukaku's body it
wasn't good enough to defeat madra
obviously but it's still a sweet move
that could slow him down
shukaku has access to wind release and
earth release
and he can seemingly combine these two
to use his signature
magnet release as well in boruto we see
shukaku form a blast of air
that can level the landscape even
impressing an ototuki
when one of his air bullets hit
gamabunta he had to admit
that it packed an unbelievable amount of
chakra and he couldn't handle much more
then there's the really cool gara and
shukaku combo called
wind released sand buckshot where gara
prepares sand particles
and shukaku propels them with a giant
gust of wind
the sand particles easily penetrate the
opponent's skin and if that wasn't
awesome enough
gara can now use the sand in their
bloodstream to paralyze the opponent
lastly i'll mention the sage art magnet
release rasengan
where six path sage mode naruto uses
shukaku's magnet release
to form arasengon with shukaku's cursill
marks on it when it makes contact with a
target the marks spread across the body
and immobilize it all in all shukaku is
a very
impressive giant sand tanuki who seems
like a jerk at first but manages to
develop
solid and hype bromances with a number
of humans including
gara and naruto next up we have the two
tails aka
matatabi matatabi is a blue blazing cat
it was sealed in yugito knee from gakure
aka the village hid in the clouds
when she was two years old later hidan
and kakuzu defeat yugito
so the akatsuki can extract matatabi out
of her
matatabi is notably more polite to
humans than most hailed beasts when
conversing with
them and now let's turn to this blue
fire cat's powers
besides having large amounts of chakra
and the ability to launch tailed beast
balls matatabi can use
fire release after it takes over
yugito's body
in the battle against the akatsuki it
launches a giant and destructive ball of
fire from its mouth despite its large
size it moves with great speed and can
send opponents flying with one swing of
its strong paw
we have seen less of some tailed beasts
than others and in this case
matatabi hasn't had as much screen time
as shukaku and so we
obviously have less info about her and
her powers so although i
like this respectful fire breathing
monster cat it
is nonetheless time to move on to the
three tails aka isobu
the giant turtle beast with a sprinkle
of crab-like and shrimp-like features
added in for your sea
loving pleasure hashirama gave isobu to
kirigakure aka the village hit in the
mist
when he was trying to foster peace and
create a balance of power
at the gokage summit eventually the
hidden leaf's own rin
close friend to kakashi and the crush of
obito
was kidnapped and made into isobus jin
churiki the plan was
for her to serve as a kind of trojan
horse once back inside konoha
the three tales would be unleashed and
would go on a rampage destroying the
village
to prevent this she threw herself in the
way of kakashi's lightning blade and
thus
bravely sacrificed her own life to
protect the village isobu revived as
tail beasts do and ended up being sealed
in the fourth mizukage
yagura yagura was singled out by donzo
along with madara hashirama and b
for being one of the few to ever achieve
true or complete control over a tailed
beast yagura as a jinchuriki was
genjutsu pretty hard by obito chiha
though
ao eventually dispelled again jutsu with
his biakugan and yagura died when the
akatsuki came to capture the three tales
it was
in the wild rather than inside ajin
churiki deidra had to drag
its full-sized giant shell back after
defeating it isobu is more timid
and like matatabi friendlier than your
average tailed beast which helps explain
in part how yagura could gain complete
control of it in addition to having lots
of chakra and access to tail beast balls
isobu has a number of sea based powers
it can move swiftly through water and
can use the technique coral palm which
on contact causes coral to form
rapidly on a target until the coral is
covering their entire body
and they are no longer able to move in
the anime
isobu can use a cool genjutsu ability
called
illusionary mist that uses past memories
to trap the target in a tormenting
illusion additionally isobu can make
like sonic the hedgehog
and roll around at high speeds its spiky
shell
means that it can cause a lot of
devastating damage
if it hits an opponent in this form
having a shell and tough skin make for
an excellent defense but its open eye
remains vulnerable to attack
when it comes to ninjutsu isobu has
access to water release as well as
yin release in the anime in the anime
isobu creates tail
beast shock waves that can repel attacks
and cause tidal waves it can launch
massive water bullets and even use
space-time ninjutsu in the anime and
that about covers this friendly turtle
giant
moving on to the foretails aka satan
taisei sun goku this four-tailed monkey
king and kakarot reference was given to
iwagakurei
aka the village hidden in the stones by
hashirama
this monkey king has red fur and green
skin understandably son goku didn't
trust humans since according to it
they only see the tailed beasts as
sources of great power
humans imprison the tailed beasts and
deny them of their true status
however naruto makes sun realize that
not all humans are like that and the
monkey king also reveals that the nine
tales name
is kurama to naruto roshi was sons jin
churiki
another name you might recognize from
dragon ball which was heavily inspired
by the journey to the west story
and naruto in turn drew inspirations
from both roshi was from iwagakure and
he was known for his lava release
which is why they called him roshi of
the lala style
kisame does manage to defeat him but he
notes that it wasn't easy to hitachi
claiming that the corrosion-style jutsu
roshi used is nothing to laugh about
this jinchuriki could use lava style to
shoot scorching rocks from his mouth
and lava release chakra mode to create a
kind of lava armor around himself it
enhanced defense and attacks
to the point that a punch could burn a
target even if direct contact wasn't
made
but back to sun specifically in addition
to massive chakra reserves and tail
beast balls
sun skilled enough in taijutsu to
deliver a nicely timed
kick against madara sun is also strong
enough to lift
other tail beasts like the eight tails
in terms of nature transformations
sun can use fire release earth release
and combine them both to use
lava release as mentioned we saw how
sansjin chudiki used lava release but i
will
add that sun could also use the floral
mountain jutsu
which sounds idyllic and nice but
actually consists of using lava release
to create a volcano this volcano
explodes with scorching rocks and lava
in every direction
giving it the appearance of a flower
lastly
sun can shoot green flames from his
mouth as seen in the anime and even in a
data book now let's move on to tail
beast number 5 kokuo
here we combine the attributes of a
white horse who has
five tails and a dolphin's head after
catching it hashirama gave it to
iwagakure along with
sun it was subsequently sealed in han of
iwagakure
also called the jinchuriki of the steam
he wore steam armor that takes advantage
of boil release
the hype armor contains a furnace on its
back that stores steam and then emits it
to increase the force of his attacks
one kick could send naruto flying so
hard that even killer b
was pushed back when he tried to catch
him kokuo
is one of the more quiet and polite biju
who wants to avoid
conflict if possible when given the
chance it prefers to seclude itself in a
forest
in addition to having massive chakra and
tailed beast balls it can ram into
targets with enough speed and force to
send them flying
in regards to nature transformations it
has access to water release fire release
and can combine these two
to use the already mentioned boil
release his jinchuriki created his
epic steam armor to specifically take
advantage
of kokuwo's boil release boil release
gives the five tails and its jinchuriki
access to steam based ninjutsu voya
release
unrivaled strength style increases speed
strength and allows one to evaporate
water
and ice on contact now let's move on to
the six tails also known as sciken
sciken is a kind of upright giant snail
with six tails clearly not all designs
are as straightforward as a fox with
extra tails
hashirama gave saiken to kirigakure
along with isobu
it eventually ended up being sealed in
utakata who left the village during the
bloody mist era
became a missing nin and died at 26
years old after the akatsuki
extracted his biju in addition to the
usual massive chakra reserves and the
ability to fire beedru bombs
saikan also has the ability to release
corrosive liquids or
gases that will burn the enemy on
contact
the gas can spread quickly and as might
guy noticed
it will instantly cause a tree to wilt
upon contact
in terms of nature transformation sai
ken can use water release
including attacks like water style syrup
trap which covers the ground in a sticky
glue-like liquid
as you probably guessed this attack can
immobilize an opponent if they step in
it
and even if they don't it limits their
mobility on the battlefield the liquid
can also be manipulated and travel up
surfaces
making it even more difficult to avoid
sai ken's jinchuriki
utakata could also use water style
bubble jutsu
he'd produce bubbles using a bubble pipe
yes that's a thing and more dangerous
than you'd think
this bubble blower can manipulate these
bubbles and cause them to blow up
at will you could combine the bubbles
with acid to make them even more deadly
and in the anime utakata could use the
bubbles to transport himself to trap
enemies drown them by filling the bubble
with water or he could fill the bubbles
with blinding powder
the possibilities go on and on who would
have thought that blowing soap bubbles
could be such a deadly and versatile
fighting style and although it may seem
a little boring that sai ken can only
use water release
we must remember that it's acid
scattering ninjutsu
also called wisdom wolf decay is unique
to it
and it can give its water style attacks
a unique twist
if it combines the two next we have the
seven tails aka lucky seven
chome chome is an insect in shining
armor
more specifically it's based off of a
rhinoceros beetle
a bug that also inspired the pokemon
heracross kishimoto chose to also give
it a medieval
knight's helmet as a skull giving it a
very cool and unique look
six of its tails are wings while one is
more like a normal tail
hashirama gave chou mei to takigakure
also known as the village hidden in the
waterfall this village is unique because
it's located in an unnamed country
and it was the only village that didn't
belong to the five great shinobi nations
to be given a biju
chome was eventually sealed in fu a
female ninja or kunoichi
from takigakure the akatsuki then
extracted the seven tails from her
causing her death so i think you see a
recurring pattern here the akatsuki
are definitely not ajinchuriki's best
friend besides nice juicy chakra levels
and access to biju bombs chome can fly
and release a blinding powder
being the insect of the group it can
also use insect-based attacks
and would have been a pretty cool bijou
for shino aburame
if he was a jinchuriki chome can also
use its big horn
like a lance to ram into enemies in the
anime
it can also surround itself with a
cocoon not only does it raise its
defense it slows down chakra absorption
the cocoon's weakness is being pierced
by a chakra blade in the right spot
which can be identified with a byakugan
unfortunately we don't have more info
about chome not even notable nature
transformations but hey at least it
looks cool and can fly
next we have a fan favorite biju the
eight tails aka gyuki
killer b's very own bijoux gyuki is like
an
ox cross with an octopus or an octo ox
if you will
hashirama gave yuki to the village
hitting the clouds along with matatabi
like other tail beasts the eight tails
would get loose and go on a rampage
causing destruction to the village the
third reikage was an absolute legend and
would stop him but he refused to give up
trying to find the perfect jinchuriki
for him because the eighth tales was
just
too important of a weapon for kumo
gakure to ignore
it was sealed into killer b when he was
5 years old eventually he went on to
befriend yuki
and gained control over it unlike its
past jinchuriki's
yuki is extremely strong kurama said
that gyuki is the second strongest after
itself albeit gyuki did tell kurama
after this not to decide
who's stronger or weaker based on tail
count gyuki actually fought the third
reikage referred to as the strongest
shinobi in kumogakuri's history until
they both collapsed from exhaustion
it's an impressive feat for both of them
and goes to show how strong they both
were
like the others yuki has massive
reserves of chakra and can also recharge
them
completely in a relatively short period
of time something epic we witnessed was
when killer bee overcame sauce case
genjutsu in a split second as he pointed
out genjutsu doesn't work against
jinchuriki hosts who have control over
their biju
the biju can agitate their chakra and
wake them up
gyuki's tentacles are also very useful a
tentacle can take the form of a killer
bee
clone that could even trick sasuke's
shotgun notably it can use its tails or
tentacles to unleash the a-tail biju
twister attack
the spinning tails create strong guts of
wind that
scent surrounding shinobi blasting off
yuki's biju ball was strong enough to
break through the so-called
impenetrable barrier of the barrier core
we also got to see yuki and kurama
charge up a much stronger bedroom ball
many times greater than even their
gigantic body sizes
and as you'd expect from an octopus-like
creature [ __ ] can use
ink to its advantage the ink can be used
to blind opponents or the ink can turn
into ink clones because why not have
clones made out of
everything and now let's move on to the
one
and only the nine-tailed fox our boy
kurama who has been
inside of our protagonist since the
story began
kurama has also been called a monster
fox
i am biased because the nine tails was
my favorite pokemon even before i
watched naruto so of course kurama has
to be my favorite tale
beast it also doesn't hurt that we've
seen the most of it and that kurama
becomes very close to naruto as the
story progresses
although kurama appeared to be a human
hating dangerous and demonic enemy at
one point with naruto's acceptance and
friendship
kurama was able to transform into a hero
who straight up sacrificed his own life
in order to save naruto and the world
from the threat of ishiki otutsuki we'll
discuss this in further detail later on
but let's just take a second to
appreciate how far kurama has come
since the beginning of the series
jiraiya explains the view that humans
had of the ninetales when he says that
the nine-tailed fox
has appeared in times of consequence all
through the ages
it's a ghastly spirit destroying
everything in its path
that's why people in ancient times
feared it as one of the divine
retributions
at one point the gold and silver
brothers working for kubo gakure
tried to capture the ninetales although
they didn't succeed
they also didn't die after being eaten
by kurama they were inside the nine
tails for two weeks
causing a ruckus in there until kurama
sent them back out
in the process they also gained some of
kurama's chakra and power
later madara would go on to use the
shotgun to take control of kurama
and use it in order to fight hashirama
senju it goes to show how
insanely strong hashirama was that even
though madara had kurma on his side
hashirama could still beat him after
that kurama was sealed inside the first
hokage's wife mito uzumaki its first jin
shuriki
next up kurama was sealed inside kushina
uzumaki
wife of the fourth hokage and mother of
the seventh mito told her that the key
to being a jinchuriki and counteracting
the ninetales hatred was to fill oneself
with love
first then even ajinchuriki could live a
happy life
at one point obito took advantage of the
fact that the seal is weakened around
the time of
childbirth and used that opportunity to
extract the nine tails like madara he
took control of kurama with a shotgun
although minato
freed kurama from obito's control it
still had an antagonistic relationship
with konoha
and continued to wreak havoc until
minato and kushina
eventually stopped it and sealed half of
it into naruto
at the cost of their lives the other
half went with minato for the time being
until it could be reunited inside naruto
down the line so you could say that the
nine-tailed fox costalized naruto's
parents
even if obito is primarily responsible
for making it possible for this
situation to take place
i'm still not too convinced that minato
should have died here
but it did make for one of the most
touching chapters in naruto when naruto
finally finds out the truth of what
happened and how much his parents loved
him naruto even ends up
looking past the fact that kurama killed
his parents which is easier to forgive
when you see the situation from its
perspective it does make sense that
kurima would act against people who see
it as a tool and decide what to do with
the ninetale without paying any regard
to what it wants
combine that with its loneliness and
distrust of humans and it's not
surprising that it would have an
antagonistic relationship with the
humans of the village
who are trying to trap it once again
against its will now on to the power of
the nine tails it's very op
and considered to be the strongest of
all the tail beasts already mentioned
and obviously this doesn't include the
10 tails which we'll get to in a bit
keep in mind naruto and kurama could
overpower five
other tailed beasts with only half its
power that gives you a sense of the
crazy power discrepancy we can expect to
see between the tailed beasts
when you see something like that you can
understand why koram insists that the
more tails you have
the stronger you are later naruto gains
kurama's full power
he eventually became capable of
summoning kurama so that he manifested
separately and they could fight apart
we talked a lot about massive chakra
reserves and kuruma specifically are on
another level kuruma had to be sealed
into the husk of the ten tails last
or else it would disrupt the balance and
the statue would fall apart
then there's the fact that part of the
nine tails chakra can be passed on to
the allied shinobi forces in order to
increase their power in chakra too
how's that for a chakra flex kuramas
clearly got chakra to spare we've seen
naruto use kurama's chakra to enter his
op9 tails chakra mode but most recently
in boruto we witnessed baryon mode which
blows
all previous forms out of the water
according to kurama
this form is like nuclear fusion it's a
similar principle to how the sun
produces energy
according to kurama unlike with the
other modes
this is a totally different beast as the
raw materials to create this energy
kurama's chakra and narutos get consumed
until one
or both of their lives run out another
interesting fact is that on contact this
form reduces the lifespan of their
opponent too
this form allowed naruto to defeat
ishikiyotutsuki
it is the strongest naruto's been
however it came at a huge price
as kunima later reveals the cost the
whole time was actually going to be its
own life
not naruto's kurama simply never told
naruto that because he knew
he wouldn't go along with it if that was
the case
so the demon fox who killed naruto's
parents ended up sacrificing itself to
help save naruto and the rest of the
world
usually you'd expect hailed beasts to
come back again eventually after they
die but kuruma implies that it's
different with baryon mode
and that naruto won't see him again
until he meets him in the afterlife this
happened recently at the time of making
this video so we'll see what happens
i wouldn't be surprised to learn that we
haven't seen the last of this demon fox
but either way we can appreciate his
amazing transformation and how much of a
difference
being treated with compassion and
kindness made for kurama along with
kurama's super charged biju balls
it also has sensor skills being able to
sense negative emotions a very useful
ability in naruto
in the anime kurama was also capable of
using fire release and wind release
being able to breathe fire and create
twisters respectively at the end of the
day kurima clearly stood above the other
tailed beasts in power but the ability
to use baryon mode was the overpowered
icing on top of the overpowered cake
lastly let's take a look at the ten
tales the being from which hagaromo
created the other tailed beasts the ten
tales is the combination of kaguya
otsutsuki and the god tree hagoromo
ended up becoming the tantalus jin
churiki making him one of the most
broken characters in naruto
later in order to prevent the
resurrection of the tenth tales and
kaguya he split the chakra up between
nine different tailed beasts a long time
later madara and obito would seek to
become the next ten tales jinchuriki
they wanted to use the insane power to
carry out their own ends and so they
needed to collect the other tailed
beasts first
this is how kurima described the ten
tales after he explained that the sage
of six paths used to say that the ten
tales revival would signify the end of
the world kuruma says and i quote
ten tales is the aggregate of the chakra
of all the biju
one tale through me he was the beginning
of chakra
and the creator god of many nations he
drank
oceans split open the earth hoisted the
mountains
he is the progenitor who is said to
create this very land
a simple way to think of it is that his
strength is the added total of all be
drew i
by myself couldn't take him on and hope
to win end quote
when naruto was attempting to sense how
strong the tenth tales was
kurima told him not to do it since he
just see how immeasurable the power
is how hype is that and keep in mind we
didn't get to see a full 10 tails that
incorporated the full power of all nine
tailed beasts which would have made him
even stronger especially since kurama
the strongest of the nine was still
inside naruto
a noteworthy flex is that it was able to
flick away
a biju ball with a finger and it can
cause natural disasters with a roar
the ten tails is also very flexible
being able to attach a part of its flesh
if it's on fire
being able to regrow lost limbs and form
additional arms that it can manipulate
at will
additionally it can form disconnected
humanoid beings that can charge enemy
forces
this ability gives the non-naruto
fighters a chance to fight
and also reminds us just how much the
tailed beast's powers remind me of the
titan shifter powers in attack on titan
in both cases there are nine powers or
beings that were originally won
you can definitely find a lot of
parallels there just saying
anyways the roots of the god tree are
opie and can extend around enemies even
big ones like the tail
beasts and absorb their chakra from them
as the 10 tails jin churiki obito
shaped these roots into dragon heads the
god tree can also create a bud that
blossoms and that blossoming will reveal
an eye at the flower center which will
be reflected by the moon and activate
infinite tsukuyomi the ultimate genjutsu
that traps all the world's inhabitants
in a genjutsu while their chakra is
siphoned off lastly once the rinnegan
wielder becomes the ten-tail jinchuriki
they unlock six-pack sanjutsu and the
truth-seeking orbs the tenth house is
associated with every kind of basic
nature transformation including fire
wind earth lightning and water
as well as wood release it also contains
the power of yin and yang release
and as already mentioned its unique and
op ability includes absorbing chakra
and that is it for all 10 tailed beasts
and their powers explained
that was definitely one of my longer
videos let me know which one is your
favorite
like i said my favorite is kurama but
i'm fully aware that that's not a very
original answer
if you did enjoy this video and want to
keep naruto videos like this coming make
sure to smash that like button these
kinds of videos
take a bunch of work so definitely turn
that like button blue
so i know you want to see more if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future naruto videos
leave your suggestions for what naruto
topics you would like me to cover next
in the comments and while you wait for
the next video to drop feel free to
check out my growing naruto playlist
which includes videos on all hokage
all kage aluzumaki altsutsuki and much
much more link to that is in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord wigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and other one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans
in grata acquire respect pate heffa liam
thompson al-jatal
dr cortman dustin scarlet the toasted
chi
bang emperor taku spidey life tinel
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis and yuno
and are pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers
angel crews anatoly kozawski cricket xp
retuin de aura
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks
hinokami and water joanne garcia the red
haired raven ted note 10 i sparky 65
fat boy games deadly saint and soul rye
slice and dice
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support mormon by going
over to patreon.com
animeapro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime uploader link to that
is in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
they've hopefully already destroyed so
yeah you can support more content now if
you prefer
whichever way to support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you